good morning John actually you know what
it's not a good morning it's a bad
morning because I am freaking tired of
getting [ __ ] around by customer
service the customer service industry is
it seems engaging our practice that I
will henceforth be colored an [ __ ]
propagation program I am defining these
a PPS as any societal program that
ignores kindness and openness and
coolness and rewards general
douchebaggery as an example so that you
can better understand when a PP is I'm
going to reenact a recent call that I
had with a customer service agent of a
company that I give my business to that
I will not mention the name of hi this
is Jeffrey from a big companies a P P
Department hi yeah my name is Hank green
my credit card was recently defrauded
and so I had to cancel my card and I
didn't realize that it was the card that
I had listed for your company's service
on automatic payment and I just got a
letter from you guys saying that you
were charging me an extra 30 bucks
because the payment didn't go through
but it was just because my card was
defrauded and I was too busy to try and
find all the places where I was listed
as as the automatic payment option and
so I thought maybe that that wasn't a
necessary charge
yeah it's perfectly legal for us to do
that well yeah I wasn't saying that it's
not legal for you to do it I just
thought that since none of the other
half a dozen companies that had that
card listed as an automatic payment
option didn't charge me anything that it
was maybe a little silly for your
company to charge me all that money I
apologize sir but that's our policy um
yeah but do you see where I'm coming
from here like it's just like it is your
company going to charge me a bunch of
money every time they're legally allowed
to do it even if you know I'm already
dealing with a bunch of crap well I'm
sorry sir but there's nothing I can do
for you oh that's just our policy that's
that's how we do it and now my friends
the moment you have been waiting for the
moment when I give in to the APB I'm not
proud I'm ashamed
but I did this is bull first I had to do
with all the bull crap because I got my
credit card defrauded and that guy will
steal the money for me and now your
company decides that they can steal more
money from me because I already got
money feeling for me this is not okay
what you're doing is just make
me act like a well and say lots of curse
words like butthole so that you can have
a justification for going to your
manager and asking me for my money back
so just go do it go a scream I get my
freakin money back and I will stop
yelling at you because I am NOT a mean
guy I'm a nice guy and I'm tired of this
I hate that you make me yell at you go
talk to your manager terribly please
hold
yes I'll hold sir we've gone ahead and
credited the $30 back to your account is
there anything else I can do for you
today no that is all you could do for me
thank you bye so I just want to send out
a message to all the [ __ ] propagation
programs in the world we've got our eye
on you what you're doing might decrease
your costs for now but in the long run
all you are doing is creating more
[ __ ] and it's not just customer
service it's every societal program that
punishes kindness and rewards
douchebaggery all of you it needs to
stop do not give in and the NPP's people
out of you the shield
I just wanted to show you that this is I
don't have one of these it's just a
flash drive duct tape on it and that
part's been in my ear